hello everyone and welcome to some
breaking news yes the rumors you've
heard are true tomorrow Java is out of
the feeder candidates tournament now he
didn't give a reason he said he's
withdrawing from some prefer due to some
personal reasons and as now there's one
spot opened up it is Maxie Marshall a
gravitating this place now if you're
wondering why it's Maxine who will be
taking his place it's not just the feed
a lot of Maxime and they want him to
play in the in candidates it's also
decided by the rules but I thought that
we're using the different rule when they
gave MVL the spot I thought it's because
I will both Dingley rent a motor job of
qualified through the fede World Cup
with winning first and second place and
I'm Maxine Marshall holograph defeated
young e for third place so it makes
sense if one of them is out like to take
more the job of then as two spots are
granted via the feeder World Cup it
would be maxime beaugeois grab and
England but it's actually not free they
published on their website as you can
see not that as you can see here the
Grandmaster from Azerbaijan had
qualified for the candidates by winning
the 2019 World Cup held in hunting man
Sisk our job will be replaced following
the procedure described in the article
two point one point II of the tournament
regulations one place is reserved for
the player with the highest average
feeder rating for the purpose of
deciding the qualifier the average Ehlo
rating from the 12 feet a standard
rating list from February 2019 to
January 2020 is used so basically now
both both Maxime and Giri have qualified
via the same criteria the the B highest
average rating over the course of 12
months so yeah really really exciting
stuff I don't know I was I was actually
very much looking forward to seeing our
job of played against everyone because
he took a really long break from chest
and then he just comes out of nowhere
and he wins the World Cup which is just
insane so I was really really wondering
how he would do but then again I'm also
very happy that Maxime will be playing
he's a very sharp player he's only gonna
make the term tournament much more
interesting and this is one such game
that I decided to show you it's from
2015 Tata Steel so really really
limits of what we can expecting as both
Fabi and MBL will be playing in the
candidates tournament but yeah I don't
know if this ever happened if anyone
ever withdrew from the candidates
tournament I'm sure I'm sure they have
like maybe maybe before but I don't know
one thing that comes to mind is Paul
Banquo giving up his spot for the Hamid
America inter-zonal tournaments - bobby
fischer and then bobby fischer went on
with his legendary streak and took it
all the way to the World Chess
Championship match and defeated Spassky
so we'll see if Maxime will do the same
if now that a job went pal Benko maybe
Maxime will go all Bobby Fischer and
simply annihilate everyone would be
would be really fun and then if he wins
the candidates and if he beats Magnus in
December then it's gonna be oh yeah
that's that's what a job was doing you
know if he didn't give up his spot then
and we would never have been champion
and so on but we'll see we'll see what
happens it's gonna be a very exciting
tournament ended this game is maybe a
glimpse into what we can expect so
without further ado let's check it out
Fabi with the white pieces opens with E
for like I said this was played in 2015
in Tata Steel masters and yeah maybe I
overdid it with the photos maybe maybe
there are be the younger than 2015 but
then again I always overdo it so now
we're not going to go into that see five
of course when you play E for you are
you're facing the absolute best Sicilian
you you've ever faced when you play
Maxie Knight f3 d6 and d4 so now that
that muck seems in the candidates
everyone's gonna have to like know
everything about the Sicilian but that's
the problem as since everyone's been
preparing for months now for the
candidates tournament except Maxine so
now he doesn't really have time to
prepare but none of the other players
have time to prepare for him so it's
really it's really gonna be wild so now
maybe they weren't expecting the
Sicilian from other players but now if
they play e4 they know they have to know
everything about the Sicilian especially
a night off and it's just gonna be crazy
I don't know this it's gonna be great
but okay C captures night characters
Knight f6 Knight to c3 and of course a6
and
thing goes for his night off variation
with h3 the Adams attack always popular
even then preparing g4 so if I first
kicking back the night 92 and now h5 by
Maxine preventing 5 is g4 with g3 Bishop
to e6 and now Bishop to G 2 so there's a
lot of theory in this in this variation
I'll just focus on the part when we when
we get out of theory Knight bt7
continuing development and now a fourth
there is one game where Alex a sheriff
tried f4 against machine partial a graph
about the maximum wounded game so here a
four is the move Bishop to e7 continuing
development castles by Fabi
and now rook to c8 putting the rotor and
I semi open file Bishop to e3 in now
Knights the B 6 and here Fabi goes B 3
takes away some very important squares
from from the night so the knight looks
a bit weird here on B 6 and now again
there is one game where I mean oddly
played against ali reza fuchsia where he
tried h4 but it didn't healed more than
a draw
so here Maxime does what he does best d5
he sacrifices upon now we always say if
you're playing the Sicilian if you can
execute d5 you should always do it but
here it comes at the price of a pawn
so here Maxime has a threat he can just
win a piece here if he if he gets the
push d4 in without this and if you don't
want to well if you want to win the
battle of d5 you have to eliminate one
of the defenders which means giving up
the bishop pair so this is what Fabi
goes for and it is kinda is the
strongest move so Bishop captures here
preparing to capture on b5 Queen
captures and b6 and now Knight captures
on d5 Knight captures eke a person d5
attacks the Bishop Bishop d7 and now c4
so here at the end of this very nice
variation Fabi has a passed pawn on d5
and he's upper pawn on the other hand
Maxime has the bishop pair and he's now
ready to start pushing in the will
Center slash King side would f5 e 4f 4
and so on
so Queen to b6 here Maxine first creates
a barrier on the dark squares so this is
a beautiful point Jimmy if Bobby starts
pushing it it's game over
so here Maxine makes sure that this will
not be possible and now a 5 from Fabi
and it is as a move 18 that this
position has never been reached again
but now that the the pawn chain is
stable Maxime starts pushing with f5 and
ok we have Queen to d3 trying to get
Maxime to push efore so we can create a
barrier of his own on the dark squares
with Queen III but first h4 by Maxine
we have g4 by Fabi he doesn't want to
open up
Maxine's rook so g4 and now Maxime could
go for captures captures and characters
which wins back the pawn and he does
have some threats with h3 going on but
Bishop h3 could be it could be a
nuisance then he gave up the e4 square
maybe Knight to c3 to a forest coming
maybe looked a rook to e1 followed by F
for opening up the position so really
really complicated stuff that it's hard
to say if it's good
so instead Maxime just castles gets his
King to safety and he's still gonna
consider consider pushing and capturing
on g4 so Knight to c3 biphobia now
saying okay if you capture I get d4
square for my knight so e for instead
and Quinta III by Fabi and now it's a
really crazy position Fabi still up a
pawn but Maxine well it's most
definitely Maxime deciding the tone of
the battle here so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the Maxim's
next move as it's really just a beauty
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting a move
with the dashed back and noticing this
beautiful diagonal so it's for those who
just wanna enjoy the show Bishop to d8
threatening Bishop to c7 and of course
Queen to h2 mate and there is no
creating a blockade here in the dark
squares because Bobby doesn't have a
dark square Bishop he gave it up to
create this massive pawn chain and a
pass deep on but now he definitely has
problems on the dark squares and it's
not easy to do something for example if
rook fd1 you make some room for the king
you can still go Bishop c7 King f1
trying to run away but now F cap % g4
now you open up the roof to the king the
Queen can still go to h2 it's just it's
just an impossible position to play for
white so here Fabi does the only thing
he can Bishop captures on e4 he's
already up a pond so he says okay I'm
gonna give up a piece for two points so
that that way I'll be down a piece but
up three pawns which is definitely
compensation and now you cannot go
Bishop c7 because now f4 is here there
is no e cap trous if three on poisson as
fabulous eliminated that point so
instead
Maxine goes F captures on e4 we have
Knight captures on e4 and now Queen to
f4
and now Maxime is very confident that he
can he can take this all the way Bobby
says okay Queen captures rook captures
and now f3 defending the knight but
Bishop to e7 again creating a barrier on
the dark squares and you cannot play
something like d6 because here and Maxie
would be more than happy to give up the
exchange with rook captures any for now
if you capture you just capture back so
why doesn't really win anything so f
captures Bishop captures here and now
Maxime would have two bishops for a rook
which is of course a much better
so instead King f2 Bobby tries bringing
the King into the game rook C to F a
threatening to capture an f3 also rook
captures night is an idea
so King III and now Bishop back to eh
now the bishop controls a lot of squares
you are still controlling these squares
which can be used to clean the pond and
also you can easily shift it to maybe g6
or or wherever if maybe see if I was
played then you have the b5 just a
useful square tucking it in for later
use c5 and now maxime has to decide what
to do c5 has been played d6 is
definitely coming so here you could go
for rook captures here it might be the
same for example F captures you capture
here with the check and now you cannot
go to light squares because of Bishop b5
check picks up the roof so we'd have to
go King D 2 and then Bishop f2 is very
strong but it's it's a weird line and a
hard hard move to find where it's really
gonna be impossible for white to
activate the rooks especially along the
F file and the two bishops will be will
be really harassing the White King but
maxeen finds a simpler idea Bishop to b5
right away
now attacking the rook and saying okay
now I'm attacking the rook if you try
rook F 2 then I'm gonna capture here and
then the problem is if you play F
captures on e4 then just Bishop captures
on c5 wins wins the rook here it's not a
problem
and after this if you play King captures
then it's just a beautiful King hunt
King Bishop captures on c5 rook the
detail and now rook to e8 with Czech
king of five but now Bishop to e3 taking
away squares from from the black king
the rookie is under attack
if you move the rook which you probably
will Bishop d7 check King g6 and now
rook to e5 and there is no defense
against through up to g5 mate or if you
play afford to prevent the Denton Bishop
to eh is made and so on so Bishop to b5
really deadly not a lot of a lot of
moves here for Fabi instead Fabi plays
b4 he says my rooks aren't really doing
anything I would very gladly give up the
route for your strong leadership and
then continue pushing my passport but
now Maxime goes into a deep thing and he
just says okay now it's time for it
rook captures an e4 with Czech capturing
the rook was also fine but this is just
much more forcing King captures King
captures rook enter now you don't want
to capture with the pawn and then allow
further trade special characters
okay bunch of characters and c5 isn't
here but you just want to get the King
as deep into the position as possible
but now rook to e8 now again still not
going after the rook but now threatening
some very nasty discoveries again it's
impossible to push because the bishop
just picks it up and mvl wants to start
cleaning up the these points which are
just closer and closer so pink the f4
preventing any any such ideas but now g5
with check with King the f5 and now King
f7 and now really taking away the
squares from the White King and it's
it's hard hard hard to say what to do so
here if you want to stop Bishop to b3
check you have to go rogue d1 but then
it's Bishop to d7 check so it doesn't
really make much difference again you
have to go in front of the rook
so here Fabi instead goes rook F the e1
but now it's it's actually just mating
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find it well I'll give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting not the first mood the first
move is easy to spot but for spotting
the second move and for those who just
wanna enjoy so it's Bishop d3 check yes
I know you all got that one so now if
king e5 which is pretty bad just Bishop
captures and c5 is made as the bishop
now covers the two squares and the rug
delivers made but the best defense is
what Fabi played rook to e4 if you wanna
if you want to continue playing now he's
hoping for Bishop captures pawn captures
who he so he gets more points to push
but here is the move you had to find
it's Bishop f6 and it was in this
position unmoved thirty five that
Fabiana karana resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
whatever you play rook the e5 is coming
with check with checkmate there is
nothing you can do here or if f4 like in
the line in a similar line we've shown
preventing rookie five then it's just
Bishop captures on e4 as now the rook is
no longer guarded so here it's it's mate
as you don't have any squares left for
the King so really amazing game
beautiful night of Sicilian and this is
this is what I meant by what's gonna
happen now that Maxime is in the
candidates tournament they they weren't
ready for him and now he's here no one
prepared for them who knows maybe maybe
everyone thought okay I'm gonna play
efore in the candidates no one plays the
Sicilian yeah that's a good idea and now
mvl is in the candidates and now you
know all hell's gonna break loose
but then again Maxime wasn't preparing
for the candidates either so it's hard
to say or who knows maybe a job of told
Maxime maybe two months ago hey man I'm
not gonna be playing the candidates just
so you know at some point I'm gonna make
it public you know anything's possible
here but yeah that's the game ended the
breaking news I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank problem ohon Evan
burr see Thomas Hoyt appalled me and
David Wallace for contributing to my
channel I think you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Murphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and hoping for more breaking
news so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend